Hey there, Shankar here. I'm guessing you've gotten the memo. It's that delightful time of year when we're encouraged to express our love for friends and family by buying them stuff. We love black bread! Yes, the first of the Black Friday shoppers are pitching tents. Jonas, a little bit more. Despite several people falling to the ground, shoppers charged ahead, fixated on door buster deals. Look at that line.
大家好，我是尚卡尔。我猜你已经收到消息了。这是一年中那个美妙的时刻，我们被鼓励通过给亲朋好友买东西来表达对他们的爱。我们爱黑面包！是的，第一批黑色星期五的购物者已经在搭帐篷了。乔纳斯，再多一点。尽管有好几个人摔倒在地，但购物者们依然冲上前去，死死盯着限时抢购的优惠。看那条队伍。
More than 100 million people expected to turn up between now and Sunday either. If you find shopping as exhausting as I do, but the psychology of shopping as fascinating as I do, today's episode is for you. It's a conversation from April that looks at how we use money to express and sometimes ignore our values. Here's the show. Hope you enjoy it.
预计从现在到周日之间，将有超过一亿人涌现。如果你像我一样觉得购物精疲力竭，但又和我一样觉得购物心理学极其迷人，那么今天的节目正是为你准备的。这是一场四月份的对话，探讨了我们如何用金钱来表达，有时甚至是忽视我们的价值观。节目开始了，希望你喜欢。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Americans have long expressed their political views with their wallets. In recent months, this has ramped up, with boycotts and with buycotts. That's why people express support by buying a company's products. For a month now, Nordstrom has been on a list of Trump-affiliated companies to boycott. This is just, it's a wonderful line, I own some of it. I fully, I'm going to just give it, I'm going to give a free commercial here, go buy it today everybody. I deleted Uber recently due to what happened at JFK Airport when it appeared that Uber
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。长期以来，美国人一直用钱包表达他们的政治观点。最近几个月，这种现象愈演愈烈，抵制和支持性购买层出不穷。这就是人们通过购买某家公司的产品来表达支持的方式。一个月以来，诺德斯特龙一直在被抵制与特朗普有关联的公司名单上。这真是，这是一句妙语，我有一部分股份。我完全，我干脆，我要在这里做个免费广告，大家今天都去买吧。我最近删除了优步，因为肯尼迪机场发生的事情，当时看起来优步
was essentially trying to break the strides, fueled the outrage and led to some people to call for a boycott of the airline. It seems like people are a little fed up and disillusioned with sort of conventional political channels where they would normally sort of conventional political channels where they would normally sort of express their political views. And so in the absence of that legitimacy, there's been sort of a rise in political consumerism. Neuropeharia is a marketing professor at Georgetown University. She studies how consumer behavior often serves psychological needs rather than economic
本质上是在试图打破罢工，这激起了人们的愤怒，并导致一些人呼吁抵制这家航空公司。似乎人们对传统政治渠道有些厌倦和幻灭，他们过去通常会在这些渠道中表达自己的政治观点。因此，在缺乏这种合法性的情况下，政治消费主义开始兴起。尼鲁·帕哈里亚是乔治城大学的市场营销教授。她研究消费者行为如何往往是为了满足心理需求，而不是经济需求。
needs. When we think about the way we spend money, we may think about the comfort of a nice pair of shoes or the pleasure of a great meal. But money also serves a deeper purpose. We use money to express our feelings, to project our status, to defend our values. The products we buy tell stories, stories that we tell others, stories that we tell ourselves. For a small coffee shop, people don't really think much of the political situation, but as soon as you put a large competitor in next door, say you put a Starbucks in next door,
当我们思考我们花钱的方式时，我们可能会想到一双舒适的好鞋或一顿美餐带来的快乐。但金钱也服务于更深层目的。我们用金钱来表达情感，展现地位，捍卫价值观。我们购买的产品讲述着故事，这些故事是我们讲给别人听的，也是我们讲给自己听的。对于一家小咖啡馆来说，人们其实并不会太在意政治局势，但只要你在隔壁开一家大型竞争对手，比如在隔壁开一家星巴克，
all of a sudden it becomes a fight between the little guy and the big guy. How money can talk? This week on Hidden Brain. Nero Paharia says she first became interested in the psychological power of consumer products because of the diamond industry. The diamond engagement ring. How else could two-month salary last forever? A diamond. I studied economics as an undergraduate, and one thing they tell you as an economics major
突然之间，这就变成了一场小人物与大人物之间的战斗。金钱如何说话？本周的《隐藏的大脑》。尼鲁·帕哈里亚说，她之所以对消费品的心理力量产生兴趣，最初是因为钻石行业。钻石订婚戒指。两个月的薪水怎么可能持续永远？一颗钻石。我在读本科时学的是经济学，经济学专业教给你的一件事是
is that people are rational. But as far as nirical tell, there was nothing particularly rational about buying a diamond. Now you can argue that diamonds are beautiful, but there are cheaper stones that are just as pretty. So then the question is, why are people spending so much money on these shiny rocks that have no intrinsic value, and you know there's effectively a perfect substitute. And then it seemed like it was all this kind of psychological stuff that people wanted
人们是理性的。但在尼鲁看来，买钻石并没有什么特别理性可言。现在你可以争辩说钻石很美丽，但有更便宜的石头也同样漂亮。那么问题来了，为什么人们要花这么多钱买这些没有内在价值、而且你知道实际上有完美替代品的闪亮石头？然后这似乎全是那种人们想要表达自己地位的心理学东西，人们想要融入婚姻方面的规范性做法。
to express their status, people wanted to kind of fit in with sort of the normative practices in terms of marriage. And it's just sort of dawned on me that products have all this psychological value and that's worth real money. I mean, a whole industry is based on just sort of pure kind of signaling and psychological value. And I found that to be really interesting and sort of at odds with this notion that people are rational. This idea made Neeru think about the other ways we use money as a signaling
我突然意识到，产品具有所有这些心理价值，而这值真金白银。我的意思是，整个行业都建立在纯粹的信号传递和心理价值之上。我发现这真的非常有趣，而且与人们是理性的这一观念相悖。这个想法让尼鲁思考了我们用金钱作为信号装置来表达我们的信仰和价值观的其他方式。我们通常通过投票或支持各种立法之类的事情来行使我们的政治意志。
device to express our beliefs and our values. We enact our political will usually by voting or supporting different kinds of legislations and things like that. So it's kind of interesting when people start taking that civic actions, these kind of civic actions into the market and then start by-coding or boycotting a certain brand or a certain company in order to express their view. And you can kind of think about it in terms of what ends up being more tangible. So if we think about voting, it's sort of an abstract process, it's not very public.
所以当人们开始把这种公民行动，这些公民行动带入市场，然后开始抵制或抗议某个品牌或某家公司以表达他们的观点时，这就变得挺有趣的。你可以从最终什么更切实的角度来思考这个问题。因此，如果我们考虑投票，这是一种抽象的过程，不是很公开。
Whereas when you buy a product or avoid buying a product, it's very tangible. If you're someone who doesn't buy flashy jewelry, you may say, okay, I'm not one of those people who uses money to talk. Maybe. Or maybe you just don't use diamonds to talk, you use coffee. I've studied the situations between small coffee shops and large coffee shops, and so I have a paper where we show that for a small coffee shop, if it's just sitting there by itself, people, you know, people don't really think much of the political situation. They just think more about the coffee, sort of about the more rational, economic features and attributes of the product. But as soon as you put a large competitor in next door, say you put a Starbucks in next door, all of a sudden it becomes a fight between the little guy and the big guy.
然而，当你购买一件产品或避免购买一件产品时，它是非常切实的。如果你是一个不买浮夸珠宝的人，你可能会说，好吧，我不是那种用金钱说话的人。也许吧。或者你只是不用钻石说话，你用咖啡。我研究过小型咖啡馆和大型咖啡馆之间的情境，所以我有一篇论文展示了，对于一家小型咖啡馆来说，如果它只是独自立在那里，人们，你知道的，人们并不会太在意政治局势。他们只是更多地考虑咖啡，考虑产品更理性、更经济的特征和属性。但只要你在隔壁放一个大型竞争对手，比如在隔壁放一家星巴克，突然之间，这就变成了一场小人物和大人物之间的战斗。
And then buying your cup of coffee is really meaningful. All of a sudden it's a spite between the little guy and the big guy, and then buying your cup of coffees really meaningful. All of a sudden it's a symbol of what you believe in. It's a symbol of you supporting the little guy, of you supporting the underdog and trying to stick it to the man. And it's so tangible, and I just find it so fascinating that that's sort of how we kind of express our political views on a daily basis, and we feel powerful in a sense that we have a say in this situation.
然后你买的一杯咖啡就真的很有意义了。突然之间，这是一场小人物与大人物之间的争斗，然后你买的一杯咖啡真的很有意义。突然之间，它是你信仰的象征。它是你支持小人物、支持弱者并试图给当权者一点颜色的象征。它是如此切实，我只觉得这太迷人了，这就是我们日常表达政治观点的方式，我们在某种程度上感到强大，因为我们在这种情况下拥有发言权。
Companies pay attention to what consumers want. They understand that people don't just want to buy a cup of coffee or a computer, they want the right story to go with that cup of coffee or computer. This is why so many Silicon Valley companies that are worth billions of dollars spend so much time telling us about their origin stories, how two kids dropped out of college to explore a dream in someone's garage. So this is what we call, we have another paper around underdog brand biographies and this sort of idea of kind of starting in a garage from humble beginnings, but overcoming obstacles to kind of fulfill your dream.
公司关注消费者的需求。他们明白，人们不仅仅想买一杯咖啡或一台电脑，他们还希望有合适的故事来配合那杯咖啡或电脑。这就是为什么那么多价值数十亿美元的硅谷公司花那么多时间给我们讲述他们的起源故事，比如两个孩子如何从大学辍学，在某个人的车库里探索梦想。所以这就是我们所说的，我们围绕弱者品牌传记还有这种在车库里从卑微起点开始但克服障碍以实现梦想的想法写了另一篇论文。
That's a really compelling narrative, especially to Americans. I think because of the whole kind of pull yourself up from your bootstraps and this whole notion of the American dream. And so companies that take advantage of that narrative, and if they use it effectively, even as they grow, can kind of remind consumers
这是一个非常引人入胜的故事，对美国人来说尤其如此。我认为是因为那种靠自己的力量站起来的整体精神以及美国梦的整个概念。因此，利用这一叙事并在他们成长过程中有效利用它的公司，可以提醒消费者
that this was a small company and they might identify with it more and penalize them less for being a large company. There tends to be a kind of an aversion or a disdain for large companies. People tend to identify a lot more with smaller companies. And you tell the story of Nantucket Nectors, which also has the same sort of start-up story. A lot of companies, they talk about how Nantucket Nectars in particular talks about how they started with a blender and a dream and Cliff Bar talks about how they started in their garage with,
这曾是一家小公司，他们可能会对此产生更多认同，并减少因其是一家大公司而对他们的惩罚。人们往往对大公司有一种厌恶或轻蔑。人们往往对小公司有更多的认同感。你讲述了楠塔基特果汁的故事，它也有着同样类型的创业故事。许多公司，它们谈论楠塔基特果汁特别是如何谈论他们如何用一台搅拌机和一个梦想起家，而克里夫酒吧则谈论他们如何在一个车库里起家，
with he was living with his dog and his skis and you know know, was cooking and is, you know, it's a sort of underdog narrative that makes use of the sort of external disadvantage, but really, you know, trying hard. And I think people really, really find that story resonating because I think we all on some level feel like underdogs and so it sort of is, can be motivating to us. Companies are also extremely skilled at selling us things that are tied to a certain sense of identity. I remember this set of ads that Apple was running some years ago where they basically suggested that people who bought Macs were hyper and cooler than people who bought PCs.
他带着他的狗和滑雪板住在一起，你知道的，当时在做饭，你知道的，这是一种弱者叙事，利用了外部劣势，但确实，你知道的，在努力奋斗。我认为人们真的非常非常发现这个故事能引起共鸣，因为我认为我们在某种程度上都觉得自己是弱者，所以它在某种程度上可以激励我们。公司也非常擅长向我们出售与某种身份感紧密相连的东西。我记得苹果公司几年前播放过的一系列广告，它们基本上暗示买Mac的人比买PC的人更亢奋、更酷。
Hello, I'm Mac. And I'm a PC. I'm a free desk. Well, I was sitting on my desk. Yeah, someone walked by, carelessly tripped over my power cord, yanked me straight down to the ground. Bam!
你好，我是Mac。而我是一台PC。我是个自由职业者。好吧，我正坐在桌子旁。是的，有人走过来，不小心绊到了我的电源线，把我直接拽到了地上。砰！
Mac would come with this power cord that connects magnetically, so when it gets pulled, it just pops right off. Everything's just kind of thought out. You know, like the tiny built-in-ice I can't find. My life is flashing before my eyes. I see a sunset in a field of beautiful wheat. Isn't that your screensaver? Yeah.
Mac会带一根磁性连接的电源线，所以当它被拉扯时，它就会直接弹开。一切都经过了深思熟虑。你知道，比如我找不到的那个微小的内置iSight。我的人生在我眼前闪过。我看到一片美丽的小麦田里的日落。那不是你的屏保吗？是的。
They were basically saying, if you buy this kind of computer, it sends a signal of the kind of person you are. It's not so much about your status, but how cool you are. Yeah, and I think being cool is also a form of status. You know, you want to, you want to, and there's actually recent research on this by Warren and Campbell. And they talk about how coolness is essentially another way of kind of signaling your status,
他们基本上是在说，如果你买这种电脑，它会发出关于你是什么样的人的信号。这与其说是关于你的地位，不如说是关于你有多酷。是的，我认为酷也是一种地位的形式。你知道，你想要，你想要，而且沃伦和坎贝尔最近对此有研究。他们谈到酷本质上是发出你的地位信号的另一种方式，
which can be very compelling to certain groups of consumers. You want to signal their autonomy, that they're not just drones and just kind of following the masses but they that they're autonomous that they have kind of control and and are kind of independently minded. There is some irony here in an advertising campaign by a major company trying to convince people that if you buy products made by that company, you're actually acting independently and autonomously. When in fact the advertising is actually making you do what the company wants you to do. Yeah, it is interesting.
这对某些消费者群体来说非常有吸引力。你想发出他们自主性的信号，表明他们不只是行尸走肉，也不只是盲目跟风，而是他们具有自主性，拥有某种控制力，并且是独立思考的。这里有一个讽刺之处：一家大公司的广告活动试图说服人们，如果你购买该公司制造的产品，你实际上是在独立、自主地行事。而事实上，广告实际上是在让你做公司想让你做的事。是的，这很有趣。
I mean, I remember in high school that there was a whole group of kids who would wear Metallica shirts and they were trying to show how different they were, but yet they were all wearing Metallica shirts and so they were were sort of, it sort of defeated the purpose on some level, but it wasn't immediately apparent to them. One thing that Neurohus found is that consumers are attracted not just to high-end brands, but to powerful brands. Walmart can be a status symbol. Yeah, it's kind of interesting, so there is this relationship between status and power.
我的意思是，我记得在高中时，有一群孩子会穿金属乐队的T恤，他们试图展示自己有多么不同，但他们却都穿着金属乐队的T恤，所以在某种程度上这违背了初衷，但这并没有立即被他们察觉。尼鲁发现的一件事是，消费者不仅被高端品牌吸引，也被强大的品牌吸引。沃尔玛可以成为一种身份象征。是的，这挺有趣的，所以地位和权力之间存在这种关系。
And so status is a way, it's sort of what we get when we have power. And so when we think about power, we can think about Walmart as being a really powerful brand. It has a lot of strength in the marketplace. And so that strength, that kind of access to power, having a lot of resources as a brand in itself, even though it's kind of a low-end brand, if you compare it to other low-end brands, that can be kind of attractive to people who care about status.
所以地位是一种方式，是我们拥有权力时得到的东西。因此，当我们想到权力时，我们可以认为沃尔玛是一个非常强大的品牌。它在市场上有很大的力量。因此，这种力量，那种获取权力的途径，作为品牌本身拥有大量资源，尽管它是一种低端品牌，如果你把它和其他低端品牌进行比较，这对关心地位的人来说还是相当有吸引力的。
When we come back, I'm going to speak to Nero about how we use money not just to express our values, but to ignore them. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us understand the economic choices we make and have real ethical consequences. The products we buy can adversely affect the environment, or take advantage of poor people in distant countries. We can buy stuff from stores that treat their employees well, or we can buy things sometimes at a cheaper price from stores that treat their employees poorly.
当我们回来时，我将与尼鲁讨论我们如何不仅用金钱来表达价值观，而且用金钱来忽视价值观。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们许多人理解我们做出的经济选择并具有真正的伦理后果。我们购买的产品可能会对环境产生负面影响，或者利用遥远国家的穷人。我们可以从善待员工的商店买东西，或者有时从以牺牲员工利益为代价的商店以更便宜的价格买东西。
Often after a big new story about conditions at sweatshops or the use of child labor, this public outrage, but as Nuru Paharia has explored, our actions don't always match our rhetoric. She wants to throw the paper on the subject title, Sweatshop Labour is wrong unless the shoes are cute. The idea there is that you kind of decide how much you like something and so you really like a pair of shoes and so then kind of the moral reasoning starts from there. It doesn't start from kind of a neutral place where you're like, you say, oh, sweatshop labor is wrong.
通常在关于血汗工厂条件或使用童工的大新闻报道之后，会引发公众的愤怒，但正如尼鲁·帕哈里亚所探究的那样，我们的行动并不总是与我们的言辞相符。她想发表一篇以此为题的论文：《血汗工厂劳工是错误的，除非鞋子很可爱》。那里的想法是，你决定你有多喜欢某样东西，所以你真的很喜欢一双鞋，然后道德推理就从那里开始。它不是从一个中立的地方开始，也就是你说，哦，血汗工厂劳工是错误的。
You know, under any circumstances, I don't want to subject people to these unfortunate working conditions. It actually starts at a place where you're like, well, the product's really nice. And the shoes look really good on me. And then you start reasoning about it. And that's called motivated reasoning. So rather than think about morality in terms of this kind of objective thing, we kind of think about it more like a lawyer. So we decide what we want.
你知道，在任何情况下，我都不会让人们遭受这些不幸的工作条件。它实际上从这样一个地方开始：嗯，这产品真的很不错。这鞋穿在我脚上真好看。然后你开始对此进行推理。这被称为动机性推理。因此，与其用这种客观的事物来思考道德，我们更倾向于像律师那样思考。所以我们决定我们想要什么。
And then we kind of come up with the reasons to support it. So we may say, oh, if we see a pair of shoes that we don't like, we may say, oh, switch up labor is wrong. I don't like switch up labor. I don't approve. But if the shoes are cute, you might say something like, oh, it's okay because people need jobs, their companies need to make money. So you'll be more likely to agree with these things because you're motivated.
然后我们想出各种理由来支持它。所以我们可能会说，哦，如果我们看到一双我们不喜欢的鞋子，我们可能会说，哦，血汗工厂劳工是错误的。我不喜欢血汗工厂劳工。我不同意。但如果鞋子很可爱，你可能会说这样的话，哦，没关系，因为人们需要工作，公司需要赚钱。所以你更有可能同意这些事情，因为你有动机。
In a sense, the shoes are really cute. You really want them. So you want to find a way to kind of reconcile your kind of distaste for this situation and the kind of the reality of it. And you've actually conducted experiments which show that people are more likely to reach for these kinds of rationalizations when they actually like a product. Yes, exactly. So if they like a product, if you show them sort of an attractive pair of shoes, they'll be more likely to agree with these economic justifications. If you show them an unattractive pair of shoes, all of a sudden they
从某种意义上说，鞋子真的很可爱。你真的很想要它们。所以你想找到一种方法来调和你对这种局面的厌恶以及这种现实。而且你实际上做过实验，表明当人们真正喜欢某产品时，他们更有可能使用这类合理化解释。是的，完全正确。所以如果他们喜欢一个产品，如果你给他们看一双有吸引力的鞋子，他们就更有可能同意这些经济上的合理化解释。如果你给他们看一双没有吸引力的鞋子，突然之间他们
become these kind of moral animals who say, oh no it's wrong. And so the idea is that we just decide what is moral based on, you know, how much we want something. What one thing you've looked at is that we're often willing to go along with products that are ethically problematic so long as we can come up with a way to distance ourselves from the unethical behavior that produced it. The more distance we can put between ourselves and the unethical behavior or the unethical action, the easier it becomes to perform. This goes to the idea that if I went to the grocery store and asked for a chicken and they
变成了那种道德动物，他们会说，哦不，这是不对的。所以这个想法是，我们只是根据我们有多想要某样东西来决定什么是道德的。你探讨过的一个现象是，只要我们能找到一种方法让自己与产生这种不道德行为的源头保持距离，我们通常就愿意接受存在道德问题的产品。我们与不道德行为或不道德行动之间的距离越大，实施起来就越容易。这就好比，如果我去杂货店买鸡肉，然后他们
went out and killed a chicken for me, I would feel worse about that that if I went to the grocery store and asked for a chicken and they went out and killed a chicken for me, I would feel worse about that than if I was just picking up the chicken from a tray. And of course, in both cases, a chicken had to be killed. But in one case, I feel like I have actually asked for the chicken to be killed. In the other case, the dirty walk has already been done. Yeah.
出去帮我杀了一只鸡，我对这事的感受会比我去杂货店要求买鸡肉，然后他们出去杀了一只鸡更糟糕，这种情况比我只是从托盘里拿走鸡肉的感觉要糟。当然，在这两种情况下，都必须杀一只鸡。但在一种情况下，我觉得我实际上要求杀这只鸡。在另一种情况下，脏活已经干完了。是的。
So there's a number of things that sort of enable us to not feel so close to the harm. Essentially, you're buying a product from a company, but what you're doing is you're hiring them to do this dirty work for you. Say any clothing company, they're the ones who hire a child and maybe under some unfortunate conditions, you're not directly actually hiring that person. But I think the second thing that happens is this idea of the order of how kind of supply and demand happen. So we live in an economy where most items are produced first. And so they're already produced, they're already in the store. And so when you go
所以有很多事情让我们觉得离伤害没有那么近。本质上，你是在向一家公司购买产品，但你实际上是在雇佣他们为你干脏活。比如任何服装公司，他们才是雇佣童工并在某些不幸条件下工作的人，你并没有直接雇佣那个人。但我认为发生的第二件事是关于供求关系发生顺序的想法。我们生活在一个大多数物品都是先生产出来的经济体中。所以它们已经被生产出来了，它们已经在商店里了。所以当你去
to the store, the damage has been done, so to speak. So it's already been done. It's already happened. But imagine that you went into that same store and you had to order your chicken or your clothes on demand. So if you order it on demand, they then they will put a child have them work under these unfortunate conditions.
店里时，可以说伤害已经造成了。所以它已经完成了。它已经发生了。但想象一下，你走进同一家店，你必须按需点购你的鸡肉或衣服。如果你按需求点购，他们就会让儿童在这些不幸的条件下工作。
And then you start feeling responsible and guilty for this situation where when it's already happened, you feel like, oh, well, it's already happened, and I'm not responsible for it. And I think people don't really kind of see this broader role that consumers have in creating demand for these kinds of products. They don't see that A causes B because it sort of happens backwards, that they actually make the product first. And then you decide if you want it. But if we lived in an economy that was all on demand,
然后你开始对这种情况感到责任感和内疚感，而当事情已经发生时，你会觉得，哦，好吧，事情已经发生了，我对此不负责任。我认为人们并没有真正看到消费者在为这类产品创造需求方面所扮演的更广泛角色。他们没有看到A导致B，因为它是倒着发生的，他们实际上是先制造了产品。然后你决定是否想要它。但如果我们生活在一个完全按需生产的经济体中，
then it would happen the other way. You would decide you want it, and then they would make it. And then there would be a stronger connection, kind of a stronger cause-and-effect connection that I think people would then feel a bit more responsible and a bit more guilty for these kinds of situations. I can imagine that people would feel horrible if they said I want a shirt and they have to send some poor nine-year-old kid into the basement to make the shirt for the next six hours. I mean, people would feel awful about that.
那么情况就会反过来。你决定你想要它，然后他们就会制造它。然后就会有更强的联系，一种更强的因果关系，我认为人们随后会为这类情况感到更多的责任感和内疚感。我可以想象，如果人们说我想要一件衬衫，而他们不得不派某个可怜的九岁小孩去地下室在接下来的六个小时里做这件衬衫，他们会感到极其糟糕。我的意思是，人们对此会感到糟糕透顶。
Yeah, and I think people wouldn't do it. And so then it kind of gets to this question of, does the economic structure and the structure of how goods are made, does the kind of logistical structure impact how we think about ethics and how we think about our own role in enabling these kinds of harms? The companies who make stuff for us are run by people, and those people have minds that work like our minds. So should Cummins know surprise that just as consumers would rather have companies do the dirty work for them, to distance themselves from the ethical consequences of their economic actions, companies often choose to do exactly the same thing.
是的，我认为人们不会那样做。所以这引出了这样一个问题：经济结构和货物的制造结构，这种物流结构是否会影响我们对道德的思考以及我们对自己促成这些伤害的角色的思考？为我们制造东西的公司是由人经营的，而这些人的大脑和我们的大脑一样运作。所以我们不应感到惊讶，正如消费者宁愿让公司为他们干脏活，以使自己与经济行动的道德后果保持距离一样，公司也常常选择做完全相同的事情。
Rather than run a factory that makes clothing under awful working conditions, why not outsource the dirty work to someone else? If a reporter I know it's details of poor working conditions, you can now plausibly say, but I didn't know about it. In many cases companies actually do outsource the harm, so rather than own the factory that makes the clothing under these terrible conditions, we outsource them to other firms that are owned by other entities. So a lot of these companies do try and claim that they had no knowledge of this, this did not happen within the boundaries of my firm.
与其经营一家在恶劣工作条件下制造服装的工厂，为什么不把脏活外包给别人呢？如果有记者我了解不良工作条件的细节，你现在可以貌似合理地说，但我不知道。在许多情况下，公司确实将伤害外包了，因此，与其拥有在这些糟糕条件下制造服装的工厂，我们将其外包给由其他实体拥有的其他公司。因此，许多这类公司确实试图声称他们对此一无所知，这并没有在我公司的范围内发生。
It turns out that both individuals and companies often prefer to be kept in the dark about unethical practices that are further up the supply chain. So there was a really, really interesting paper by Julie Irwin and some other colleagues who wrote a paper on this idea of willful ignorance. And the idea was that you had a product and you had access to a whole bunch of different pieces of information. And one of them was the labor conditions or the environmental conditions.
事实证明，个人和公司往往都更愿意对供应链上游的不道德做法保持无知。所以朱莉·欧文和一些其他同事写了一篇关于这种故意无知想法的论文，非常非常有趣。这个想法是，你有一个产品，你可以获得大量不同的信息。其中之一就是劳动条件或环境条件。
And the question was, do people actually ask for this information? You can look at it if you want, but you could decide not to look at it. And it turns out people didn't want to look at that information because they didn't really want to be confronted with this kind of conflict between their beliefs and what they really wanted. And they found this effect was stronger for people who cared more about labor issues, who cared more about environmental issues.
问题是，人们真的会索要这些信息吗？如果你想的话你可以看，但你可以决定不看。事实证明，人们不想看这些信息，因为他们真的不想面对这种信念与他们真正想要的之间的冲突。他们发现，对于那些更关心劳工问题、更关心环境问题的人来说，这种效应更强。
They were more likely to avoid this information in order to kind of avoid this conflict. Think of the deep irony of what Nero just said. The folks who care the most about ethics might be most willing to turn a blind eye to unethical business practices because they know if they found out about those practices, they would feel obliged to do something about it. We've talked about the many ways in which consumers and companies play games with one another, using products to speak on their behalf, or using products behind which they can hide. But there's one dimension of economic activity we haven't explored, and that's time.
为了避免这种冲突，他们更有可能回避这些信息。想想尼鲁刚才所说的话中所包含的深刻讽刺。最关心道德的人可能最愿意对不道德的商业实践视而不见，因为他们知道，如果他们发现了这些实践，他们就会觉得自己有义务做点什么。我们已经讨论了消费者和公司互相玩游戏的多种方式，他们用产品来为自己发声，或者用产品作为掩护。但经济活动中还有一个我们尚未探讨的维度，那就是时间。
I asked Nero how some of us use our calendars to broadcast our social status. It used to be that people once broadcast their social status by being idle, but that idea has been turned on its head in the United States. It turns out nowadays that people who are busier actually seem to have more social status. So rather than somebody who is very wealthy, who could waste their time, take fancy vacations, invest in learning these kind of archaic mannerisms. It turns out the person who works really hard, who's really busy, who's very effortful, is the one who's seen to have more social status.
我问尼鲁，我们当中有些人是如何利用日程表来广播我们的社会地位的。过去，人们曾通过无所事事来广播他们的社会地位，但在美国，这种观念已经被颠覆了。事实证明，如今那些更忙碌的人似乎拥有更高的社会地位。所以，相比于一个非常富有、可以浪费时间、进行豪华度假、投资学习这些陈旧繁文缛节的人，
And I think in part, that is because we live in a society that values social mobility. So we actually conducted the study in the US, and we conducted the same study in Italy. And we found that for Italian people, they thought the person who was living a life of leisure had more status. Of course, they have so much money, they can just relax all the time. Whereas in the US, they thought the person who was working all the time actually had more status. And I think what was going on was that in the US people sort of value this sense of earned status. And I think what was going on was that in the US, people sort of value this sense of earned status. So status can be earned in the US, where I think in Italy, it's more of a society where status is inherited.
事实证明，那个工作非常努力、非常忙碌、付出很多努力的人，才是被认为拥有更高社会地位的人。我想部分原因是因为我们生活在一个重视社会流动的社会中。所以我们实际上在美国做过这项研究，我们在意大利也做了同样的研究。我们发现，对于意大利人来说，他们认为过着悠闲生活的人拥有更高的地位。当然，他们有那么多钱，可以随时放松。而在美国，他们认为一直在工作的人实际上拥有更高的地位。我想发生这种情况的原因是，在美国，人们倾向于重视这种获得的地位感。我想发生这种情况的原因是，在美国，人们倾向于重视这种获得的地位感。因此地位在美国是可以获得的，而在意大利，我认为那是一个地位更多是继承的社会。
So for example, my co-author is Italian, and she's always talking about how people come from good families or not. And so there's very much this idea that your status isn't necessarily something that you earn, but you inherit. And so in that sense, working hard really wouldn't get you anywhere, whereas in America you have this sense that you can actually climb the ladder. And so celebrities, for example, might say instead of saying, you know, I make one movie every year and I get to hang out on the beach for the other 10 months of the year, they actually are suggesting, oh my god, I'm so overworked.
例如，我的合著者是意大利人，她总是谈论人们是否出身名门。因此，这种观念非常普遍，即你的地位不一定是你赢得的，而是你继承的。所以在某种程度上，努力工作并不能让你去到任何地方，而在美国，你有一种感觉，你实际上可以往上爬。因此，例如，名人们可能会说，他们不说我每年拍一部电影，其余10个月都可以在海滩上闲逛，他们实际上是在暗示，天哪，我太劳累了。
Yeah, so we actually looked at tweets of celebrities who were tagged with this hashtag Humble Bragg, this idea of bragging, but sort of disguising it as a complaint. And a lot of the tweets we found had to do with being busy. So I have to be in the recording studio this morning, and then I have a book meeting in the afternoon and then I have to travel to New York in the evening and Hashtag
是的，所以我们实际上查看了被贴上“炫耀性谦虚”（Humble Bragg）这个标签的名人的推文，这种想法是炫耀，但将其伪装成抱怨。我们发现很多推文都与忙碌有关。所以今天早上我必须去录音室，下午有一个图书会议，然后晚上我得去纽约，还有话题标签
I have no life, you know, these kinds of tweets. You're trying to say something about yourself. You're busy, you're really important. You don't have time to do other things. And so, you see that on social media that's kind of an acceptable and effective way to show your status by telling people how busy you are. Newer I want to ask about your own life, which is I understand that growing up, you came from a family that in some ways prized not demonstrating its commitment to status,
我没有生活，你知道，诸如此类的推文。你试图表达关于你自己的某种看法。你很忙，你真的很重要。你没有时间做其他事情。因此，你在社交媒体上看到，这是一种展示你地位的可接受且有效的方式，那就是告诉人们你有多忙。尼鲁，我想问问你自己的生活，据我了解，在你成长过程中，你来自一个在某些方面不屑于展示其地位承诺的家庭，
that actually prized not buying the expensive things as a way to show off. So I'm of East Indian origin and my parents immigrated to this country and it turns out in East Indian communities showing your social status is a very, very important thing. So people are really, really motivated to show their status and when I was growing up that was happening through buying really expensive cars. So a lot of my parents' friends, they had jaguires and they had Mercedes and I remember I went to a friend's house one time and they had a jaguire. She was also Indian and I asked her she was complaining about her mom kind of being frugal about different things.
实际上以不买昂贵的东西来炫耀为荣。我是东印度血统，我的父母移民到这个国家，发现在东印度社区里，展示你的社会地位是一件非常非常重要的事情。所以人们真的非常渴望展示他们的地位，当我长大的时候，那是通过买非常贵的车来实现的。所以我父母的许多朋友，他们有捷豹，他们有奔驰，我记得我有一次去一个朋友家，他们有一辆捷豹。她也是印度人，我问她，她抱怨她妈妈在各种事情上都很节俭。
And I said, oh, that's so strange because she's frugal and yet you have a jaguire. And she said, oh, well, that's just to show off. And I just, the candidness of that moment really, really, you know, sparks something in my mind. Like, wow, people are just trying to show off. And my mom also would often complain about how all her friends would buy these expensive cars and the only reason they were doing it was to show off. So I just kind of got really fascinated with this idea of showing your social status. And I think kind of an evidence of how things are shifting now towards maybe towards something
我说，哦，这太奇怪了，因为她很节俭，然而你们却有一辆捷豹。她说，哦，好吧，那只是为了炫耀。我只是，那一刻的坦率真的，真的，你知道，在我脑海中激起了一些东西。就像，哇，人们只是在炫耀。我妈妈也经常抱怨她所有的朋友都买这些豪车，他们这样做的唯一原因就是为了炫耀。所以我开始对这种展示社会地位的想法着迷。我认为这可以说是事物现在如何转向某种事物的证据
like busyness. Now all her friends are retired and they all brag about how busy they are. And now my mom complains about everyone talks about how busy they are all the time. So I think, you know, it's sort of an evolving, kind of an evolving mechanism. Nero Baharia is a marketing professor at Georgetown University. Nero, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. at Georgetown University. Gnero, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me.
比如忙碌。现在她所有的朋友都退休了，他们都在吹嘘自己有多忙。现在我妈妈抱怨每个人整天都在谈论自己有多忙。所以我觉得，你知道，这是一种不断演变的，某种不断演变的机制。尼鲁·帕哈里亚是乔治城大学的市场营销教授。尼鲁，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。在乔治城大学。尼鲁，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。
This week's show was produced by Maggie Pennman. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Renee Clark, and Parth Shah. Our unsung hero this week is Steven Skip. Steve's the host of Morning Edition, and he played a vital role in developing Hidden Brain on the radio. He loves learning new things and approaches every story with an enthusiasm that's infectious. Shankar, I'm so honored that you were willing to take a little bit of your very precious
本周的节目由玛吉·佩曼制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、蕾妮·克拉克和帕思·沙阿。我们本周的无名英雄是史蒂芬·斯基普。史蒂夫是《早间版》的主持人，他在电台《隐藏的大脑》的开发中发挥了至关重要的作用。他喜欢学习新事物，并以一种具有感染力的热情对待每一个故事。尚卡尔，我很荣幸你愿意花一点你非常宝贵的
time. I barely have time to say thanks to you. For more hidden brain, follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and look for our new radio show now airing on many public radio stations across the country. I'm Shankar Vidantam. This is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
时间。我几乎没有时间对你表示感谢。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在脸书、推特和Instagram上关注我们，并寻找我们目前在全国许多公共广播电台播出的全新广播节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。